[Music]  welcome to a productive day I started my  day with a sip of coffee and exercise I  came home from gym around 9 30 and  headed to the institute around 10 30.  the day was quite hectic I had to finish  two qpcr experiments which are essential  for my upcoming paper I had to finish  some immunohistochemistry experiments  which are also essential in between I  head to the canteen grab some coffee and  sandwich came back and I had to finish  RNA extraction before I could go back to  home I left the institute at around six  o'clock  today me and my girlfriend went to a  Sizzler place for a quick dinner while  coming back at around 7 30 we enjoyed  the nice sunset by the Marine Drive and  thereby finished my productive day on a  happy note  [Music]